then there's a lot of good games around
here but one of my favorite things to do
is to go around the indie mega booth and
then kind of check out all the cool
Indies this very particular TGS oh boy I
think I saw one of the coolest things I
have ever seen
absolutely I saw a party console you
suddenly did and I saw it too
it was it's two dudes from Argentina I
think yes who have built a home console
called the dead boy time and there
they're known for this right like the
open arcade cabinet and like the curtain
Tina basically calm oh you're like for
that cabinet but these guys basically
honed their skills and made their own
console that plays very similar to
arcade style game yeah I almost like I
think it's like a cross between an
arcade game and like an Atari 2600 game
like a best-of cart you'd buy like a 256
game car let me break this down of how
radness is it's got four controllers
that are very simple basically two
buttons your buttons and it shows the
score on the hardware itself and then
there's a bunch of knobs on it and then
you basically get to be the DJ yeah so
it's it's five player
yes right away it looks like somebody is
the dungeon yeah yeah exactly someone's
there to just like mess with everyone
else so four players they've all got
buttons and then one dude can just dial
it up and down with what looks like
almost like an audio desk that a DJ has
like you said and it changes all kinds
of things like we played a space game
where we were spacemen fighting each
other and he kept making us move slower
gave his input lag made us bigger
smaller all kinds of things it was
amazing that's right and when you're
doing that and he can do this in real
time you know he's constantly changing
up on us and he's also changing the
games with these massive do something
arrow buttons that are on this thing and
just it's just the whole the hardware
itself to touch and feel is so
satisfying like it's like the buttons
are really big and they make a really
satisfying click when you push them in
and it's so colorful and so great what I
really liked is when we were given the
controller's we didn't know which one
was left and right so on when it's set
when you boot it up it says Dabo tone
and when you press your colored buttons
the D or the O or the bill do so on and
so on will move depending on which one
you're pushing which I thought was a
brilliant piece of design yeah they've
actually really thought
through it is silly it is kind of yeah
crazy idea that something that you think
you just like bring a bunch of buds over
and have some beers yeah but it's well
designed and there's some really fun
games in there from being like oh
there's another space one where each of
the buttons is a piece of your jetpack
yeah so you're pushing yourself left or
right based on these button there's like
a toilet one really the toilet my
favorite people are falling into the
toilet I don't even know how you win
that one I had a great time I think it's
one of the best games I've ever seen at
TGS in the NDA group ever I think it's
it's absolutely hilarious and I want to
see more with it I want to see what
these guys do next
absolutely and I want this hardware I
want to know what everyone is a party
console in every home so in case this
thing is up your guys's alley it's
called the double tone and it's made by
the videogame oak company which I really
enjoy both of those name absolutely they
just fun to say everything about it is
fun apparently they're just like too rad
dudes making fun game yeah and I hope I
hope I see more of it my mom helped
bring him one of those down the get in
spot anyway uh thank you guys for
watching and that was some more TGS
coverage and for everything else video
games stay tuned
you